pas de nouvelles fn
rappel entrepôts lèvera pas lui
bâle est d'accord c'est vrai que ça fait
un petit moment maintenant donc allez
c'est parti
je vais prendre ma douche avant c'est
par respect pour les médecins
[Musique]
c'est bon je suis toutefois pas c'est
parti pour la 15ème séance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
ok voilà c'est fini donc c'était la 15e
aujourd'hui le médecin a repris des
réglages qui était assez semblable à ce
qu'on faisait avant c'est à dire à plus
proche de ce que la technologie pic au
furet est capable de faire donc un effet
plus mécanique et - thermique
c'est à dire ça tabasse plus sur le
pigment mais ça chauffe moins donc
normalement je devrais avoir moins de
brûlures et ça déjà c'est une bonne
nouvelle
ensuite le médecin est plutôt content de
du résultat et de l'avancée des travaux
par rapport aux dernières aux dernières
séances sur le cas d'un art science il
s'était dit ça n'avance pas très vite là
quand même
ça progresse je suis assez d'accord avec
lui mais je spoile pas je vous verrai ça
la fin de la vidéo comme d'habitude mais
donc bon petit petite satisfaction
d'emblée ça continue à progresser voilà
ça c'est pour la bonne nouvelle du jour
pour pondérer un petit peu et peut-être
pour la moins - bonne nouvelle du jour
donc il ya des endroits où l'encré est
pratiquement complètement partie
d'ailleurs ça s'entend pendant la séance
et des endroits il passe on n'entend
plus les petits cliquetis les petites
explosions acier significative du laser
qui fait péter les pigments donc c'est
toi qui as vraiment les endroits où il
ya plus grand-chose à faire péter donc
ça c'est plutôt c'est plutôt cool
il ya des endroits où il en reste quand
même encore un peu mais bon vu que ça
fonctionne bon bonnes raisons d'espérer
que ça finisse par marché complètement
en revanche il ya des endroits et à vrai
dire le médecin de la structure
précédente du centre de laser précédent
avait déjà un peu sous entendu ce truc
là
gili à des endroits où manifestement
l'encré partie mais j'ai une petite
hyper pigmentation de la peau c'est pas
méchant mais il ya des endroits où il ya
plus d'encre il reste pourtant une un
trait qui ressemble aux traits du
tatouage c'est ma peau qui s'y perd
pigmentent un peu par endroits ça peut
arriver avec le laser
ça reste une ombre donc c'est pas
quelque chose de
c'est pas quelque chose de très très
marquée c'est pas vraiment un trait de
tatouage mais il ya une petite ombre
le conseil du médecin c'est de m'acheter
un string
voilà alors pourquoi m'acheter un string
parce que selon lui ce genre de truc là
ces choses qui à terme disparaissent sur
les parties du corps qui ont été des
tatoués avec l'alternance bronzage des
bronzage etc
les pigments ski sarcey c'est de la
mélanine a donc cédé pigments qui sont
assez similaires à ceux du bronzage donc
avec l'alternance sur l'ipod seuil
machin était apparemment c'est le genre
dhombres qui finit par disparaître assez
facilement sauf que moi évidemment vu
que c'est sur ma fesse et que je ne
pratique pas le naturisme encore que
pourquoi pas bah il m'a dit entièrement
bronze et des fesses et des bronzes et
des fesses et voilà c'est ça axelera la
disparition de ceux de ses petits ces
petites ombres jeu je vais y réfléchir
alors je vous tiens au courant mais je
vais je moi je
je vais y réfléchir
[Musique]
alors avant de vous reparler d'un petit
truc que j'ai réalisé en préparant cette
vidéo bon on va passer tout de suite aux
rives il donc voilà la photo du tatouage
il ya deux mois maintenant parce que
c'était il ya deux mois la dernière
séance voilà à quoi ça ressemblait et
voilà la photo que j'ai prise ce matin
juste avant la séance du jour
encore une fois les photos sont pas
super fidèle à la réalité mais on voit
quand même très nettement qu'il ya des
endroits où ça continue à disparaître
les traits continuent à disparaître
lancre continue à se résorber
donc je suis satisfait vous êtes
nombreux à nous demander si je garde
espoir si je pense vraiment qu'un jour
ça finira par partir complètement
oui et j'irai jusqu'au bout puisque
vraiment l'idée encore une fois ces deux
d'aller au bout de la démarche est de
voir sauf si à un moment où le médecin
dit arrêté on n'aura pas mieux c'est pas
la peine de continuer voilà moi je
continue pour voir si vraiment ça va
finir par partir complètement je
n'abandonnerai pas du cjb c'est la peau
de mon cul donc voilà première première
première chose on voit que il se passe
il se passe des choses et comme je
disais j'ai repensé à un truc marrant il
ya un an pile vraiment jour pour jour je
faisais ma dernière séance dans l'ancien
centre de détatouage dans l'ancien
centre laser et je me suis dit que
c'était pas mal c'était l'occasion de
faire un petit un petit comparatif parce
que on oublie vite ce mois la mémoire
donc il ya un an déjà
tout bêtement le tatouage ressembler à
ça et donc bien on vient de le voir mais
à côté voilà aujourd'hui ressemble à ça
mais surtout il ya un an pendant les
séances de laser jeu ressemblait à ça
et aujourd'hui je ressemble à ça
voilà vous voyez qu'il ya une petite
différence et pas seulement parce que le
pico sur ferait moins mal que l'autre
méthode encore que ça dépend des
réglages parce que j'ai eu des séances
avec des réglages qui était vraiment pas
très loin de l'ancienne technique
la vraie grosse différence j'en ai déjà
parlé mais vraiment notez le bien la
vraie grosse différence c'est la crème
anesthésiante donc vraiment si vous
entreprenez entreprenait une crypte
libye une démarche de détatouage avait
clamé une ordonnance pour de la pommade
anesthésiante ça change la vie ça sert à
rien de souffrir pour rien ça ne modifie
pas l'efficacité du laser résultat est
franchement je vous garantis et encore
moi j'ai que des petites races est un
donc si vous avez des gros aplats de
couleur ou de houdon bras faire partir
la crème anesthésiante c'est même pas
une option
voilà donc c'est mon petit conseil du
jour avec les nouveaux réglages là je
vais pouvoir avoir un rendez vous un
petit peu plus tôt ou là c'est à dire un
mois et demi donc mais on se retrouve à
ce moment là pour prendre de nouvelles
de mes fesses d'ici là bien sûr le
radeau de vidéos toutes les semaines
comme d'habitude donc en attendant pas
qu'est ce que vous faites
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Musique]